tous les matins aux aurores d'idées
soulagé sur les quais de la gare de
mâcon c'est un navetteur il fait
quotidiennement le trajet entre son
habitation et son lieu de travail
ils sont cinq mille cinq cents dans le
pays mâconnais à se rendre ainsi sur la
métropole lyonnaise
pour eux pas question de quitter leur
confort bourguignon pour le boulot tnt
du mètre carré
je peux avoir quand même maison plus
grande
ici à mâcon que ce que j'aurai dans les
environs de lyon qua non et puis aussi
c'est vrai qu'on a pas envie d'habiter
aliments non fort tout cas pas dans les
environs du ni même dans le sens des
6,25 on habite à la campagne donc on va
peut-être
parce que j'aime prendre un boulot sur
lyon
plus simple les enfants sont là-bas et
depuis mâcon ça leur coûtera 120 euros
par mois dont la moitié prise en charge
par l'employeur pour les premiers
arrivés qui peuvent s'asseoir
le train est bien plus confortable que
leur voiture vous devrez avoir toujours
des avantages c'est à dire d'être assis
de pouvoir venir profiter les trajets ce
qui malheureusement n'est pas le cas de
l'année mercredi ça se passe votre main
et beaucoup d'inconvénients mais malgré
tout si on fait la comparaison avec le
véhicule
eh bien je pense qu'on gagne son temps
victimes de leur succès les parkings de
gars comme ici à mâcon sont toujours
saturé et les trains rapides mans bondé
aujourd'hui angélique a de la chance
elle peut s'asseoir après thierry par
contre très passante donc on n'a souvent
pas de place pour s'asseoir
je pense qu'il faudrait soit ajoutée des
wagons s'ajouteraient des trains mais
vraiment pas ce que c'est vraiment un
poids très conséquent
45 minutes plus tard didier est arrivé à
bon port les navetteurs retourne ce soir
sur mâcon en train forcément